buzz buzz pretty young lady adorable
yeah she's super cute but even full of
metal mouth no oh by the way that's i
mean but also invisalign no no this line
sucks dude is it yeah my wife got
invisalign i go you're getting plastic
surgery at 50 and you're choosing your
teeth yeah like let's start with
[Music]
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
i gotta find something other than let's
go to say yeah
everyone says let's go and i don't want
to be the guy that goes let's go let's
[ __ ] go because you hear every meat
head in college going nut [ __ ] let's
go or let's do that let's do this let's
let's let's tape up the dog's mouth and
rape it
another one is uh on social media like
i was trying to post you know i had all
these shows in tacoma they're sold out
and i was gonna put tacoma you savages
and i saw brian post being like ontario
you savages let me see rogan will you be
like you savages i'm like yeah
there's a good point this is a good
point we come up with a different way we
talk about this yeah tell me when we're
ready to record
are we rolling right now okay so because
you guys were talking about phrases that
are overused let's go is way overused
and i've used it i've used it i've used
it is it tom brady did he create it you
think yeah let's go let's i don't think
he said let's [ __ ] go but let's let's
go he did it with that fake football
video which i totally fell for yeah me
too i'm such a [ __ ] rube i would have
bought so much snake oil back in the
[ __ ] 1800s that'd get me too oh
but i think that's where we get our
sayings right because he says let's go
so you'll see like i'll say like
whatever la jolla comedy store august
28th through the 30th let's go yeah i
put in lfg one time thinking i'd slide
it under the uh yeah like a fight
baby the other one and then now i'll
tell you i'll take ownership to being a
part of
of sayings that get set on podcasts and
then you start saying them savage was
one of them
savage starred with i think rogan owns i
think he copyrighted savage okay rogan
was guilty of almost all of them praise
odin do you remember praise yeah i don't
use that one but okay praise odin was
one i was guilty of but you'd hear it on
a podcast and then if you didn't realize
he was saying it a lot you just realized
you heard it a lot and then it enters
your vocabulary and then you're in a
[ __ ] bar in hawaii going praise odin
she's like you're a [ __ ] white
supremacist praise odin but at that
point too because i i used to say it all
the time i'd say 100 100 percent oh my
god now rogan says 100 100 if you say i
say percent so [ __ ] much i think
that's my thing i gotta be honest
i'm 100
i am definitely one hundred percent call
down to girl right now i am 100 i am 100
100 dude 100 percent
start start it starts starts starch
feels good to say like when a guy gets
knocked out but god he got started and
it's so applicable because it is just a
legit i mean have you ever been starched
oh yeah
yeah oh yeah i've had some tough days
on tv oh yeah i've been i've been
starching my underwear in front of
millions of people in brazil my whole
family flew out there for it
and i'm and i made 14 grand
oh my god yeah holy [ __ ] that's how much
you made for that yeah to get knocked
out by no gear it's funny though because
like i was in tacoma last week and they
they my brother's my manager so they hit
my brother the check and i you know i
i like to look like you do i like to
look at the tickets all the numbers
stuff like that so he gives it to me and
i'm like i'm not terrible and he was hey
that's four times the amount you made to
get knocked out by nogueira i'm like
good point brother good point brother
that was i was thinking about that today
i i remember the time i remember people
turning on me
like fans when they found out that i was
also a businessman really yeah like
people going ah
come on bert you care about you're
responsible you're [ __ ] an alcoholic
right you're a piece of [ __ ] alcoholic
you know you care about numbers i
thought you were like us yeah you're
[ __ ] rollerskates drunk as [ __ ] with
your kids in a speedo right thank you
and i was like yeah i'm doing that to
sell [ __ ] tickets [ __ ] yeah man
yeah you're you're one of the guys that
i think probably more so than anybody
knows the most about like ticket sales
raising the prices are you ready you
ready for some inside baseball please so
i go on and this by the way i know this
is people are gonna be like oh
you mean theo's not really autistic like
what the [ __ ]
you
i can't i cannot listen to theo anymore
because i get angry how good he is how
good he is
try doing a show with him can i just
tell you and then i have to use these
you know i have my roast but then his
are like
just you know who you well you look like
you had security for the colgate tooth
but you're like what the [ __ ] did that
come from a bridge is just a brave
street like in you like
but you know you know i'm being very
real right now and he may not admit this
because a lot of people don't want to
admit who discovered them but i
discovered theo i discovered theo you
think you did because i feel like i did
no no no because when i met him he's
making two grand a weekend and i said
papa you're [ __ ] crazy talented have
my podcast studio start doing that and
then come on my show and then now he's
making i mean not more money than you
but more money than most people he's
moving he's making more money than me
because i'm [ __ ] a bunch of suckling
[ __ ] vampires that he has got to pay
for that live in a house with him my
family my family yeah i hear that i hear
that
no me and amy schumer discovered
theophone we discovered we were the
first people i will i will say this i
will say this hand on the bible and i
would actually wish there was a way to
make this test
we discovered type in when reality bites
back we discovered the brilliance of
theo vaughn and reality bites back like
we
would look at each other and go he he
actually might be
one of the funniest people we've ever
met what year's reality bites back can
you tell me like 2008 you'll never hear
it in 2008. this one for me is amy
schumer and i
a couple of times
sat
privately and like he is the funniest
human he's saying things that are are
that the room's not catching and we
would catch he said in in the if i had
the if i had could buy that final
episode we did where they i think theo
wins it and they award him the money if
i is that that's like uh there's a
reality show okay you were on it too oh
dude pull up the list of who was on was
it was it mtv no it's comedy central
theo got his degree from mtv the uh it's
it's bur chrysler tiffany haddish moment
amy schumer theo vaughn jesus christ
kyle cease
can i tell you what is [ __ ] brilliant
about this reality show chris fairbanks
and kyle c sharp for the first
elimination theo won the first challenge
and so he gets to pick who goes home is
it physical challenges oh yeah it was
physical
that's the other thing about theo he's
way more athletic than you think oh and
by the way he's a
in reality
format he knows how to he knew how to
play the game yeah he's a beast he knew
what to do he knew not to to like be the
loudest guy to just kind of fly under
the radar and do his job and be funny
and make friends with everyone and he
won the first challenge he won the first
challenge and then he gets to pick who
goes home and this is what's is so
hilarious chris fairbanks comes up to me
and goes
i don't want to go home i need this
money he's got like eight grand an
episode for this show and he goes i need
this money and i he goes what do you
think i should do and i said well i just
go up to theo and tell him not to send
you home
and he goes okay so he went to theo and
he goes hey theo i really need this
money can you not send me home and
theo's like
that's not how it works but sure
and so he just got up and he goes kyle
sees you're going home the guy was like
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] and he was like
well he asked me not to do that he told
me not to send mommy they're like the
sound and and chris fairbanks [ __ ]
hilarious but we
i it was like the beginning brilliance
of theo of like where amy and i
appreciated just how funny it was and
just how many people at that time comedy
was different and and how many people
weren't getting it yeah like did not get
he's like i remember him telling comedy
central they're like you know what you
guys want to do if you had a show and he
was like i don't know um
i would i'd like to do a show about how
to make like a glass of water
and we're like terrible and so he
shot it he shot it oh they actually shot
yeah theo shot but they've ingrained the
video of how to make a glass of water
he's been telling me for
since i started with them he's been
thinking about like kids youtube
channels and he wants to do one where
the kids smell different farts
it would work
he i went to his house and watched him
filmed a video of making a glass of
water and i was going to stop laughing
he's the most interesting one of the
funniest [ __ ] human beings and and i
mean this and this is the part of the
behind the scenes that
he's also a very [ __ ] very smart
comic and he sits and he thinks about
comedy a lot of times yeah so like i
think that you know that's part of the
making of the sausages you think theo
just spews he's constantly jokes he's
constantly thinking of comedy and that's
what makes a great comic amy schumer and
i dude the one of the funniest if he's
not thinking of comedies crying but yeah
yeah
the me
me and amy me theo vaughn and red grant
win a challenge right and and we win a
challenge with lunell
and lunell
uh says for the reward you guys get to
take a bath with me do you know who
lunell is
do you know
you take a bath with me right and so
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so people would
know her from uh borat yeah and so we're
like and so he and i are like [ __ ] yeah
so we all we all have a few cocktails
and we get ready to take a bath and
they're like hey
um
uh i forget what they said but i wasn't
listening and and it was something to
the effect of make sure you wear a
couple pairs of bathing suits because we
want you guys to take your bathing suit
off and i didn't theo and i didn't hear
that and neither did red so nell heard
that so lanelle had two bathing suits on
so we get in the tub
comedy central the president of comedy
central at the time lauren correa i
think that's her name lauren crayo
is
at the filming elizabeth there's another
head of copy central elizabeth who's
there everyone's in this [ __ ] room in
a bathroom
and we're and we've been drinking and
lunell gets in the bathtub and goes i
hope your boy's ready to get naked and
throws off her bathing suit and theo and
i take off our bathing suits as does red
and lunell with her foot goes wait i
feel someone's dick
and theo and i were like yeah we're all
naked right now and she was like you
guys didn't wear extra bathing suits and
theo theo and i just stand up naked
we're like no
and everyone's like oh [ __ ] where's that
horn and like red's naked
we're all naked in the bathtub the
president it's about to be a gang bang
president of comey central's like
she's all no no no no no no no no no no
no
lunella's laughing so [ __ ] hard and
those were the golden ages of freaking
comedy central too that was and that
that show was so [ __ ] funny and but
that's where amy and i fell in love with
theo like just and and i don't know it's
fun to watch him i i can't watch him
anymore cause i watch his right he did a
[ __ ] joke the other day i saw that i
don't even know where i saw he goes uh
he's talking about uh
uh
reincarnation have you ever heard his
joke about reincarnation i don't want to
tell cause i don't want to ruin it yeah
it was [ __ ] brilliant yeah shooting a
special
is it this month or next month this
month august 12th which you know if you
see his first rush on netflix you know
it's it's good this is an evolution but
it's like dude compared to what he's
doing now it's not even close well it's
like when we did that i've been trying
to do this forever and it's just caught
being uh
jeff foxworthy with the blue comedy tour
to get everybody together so we had a
one stop at the orpheum theater it was
like 3 500 takes we sold two shows out
it was uh big j okay
bro this is four years ago
i remember that show big j orchestra ari
um brian myself and then theo
and so we're trying to figure out the
lineup so we had a host i went first
then i think it was big j then ari then
brian and then uh theo was like i'll
just go last man like but he felt
uncomfortable because he wasn't the
theovan at the time this is four years
ago he was just like rumblings like we
all knew who good he was he's like i
guess i'll try some new [ __ ] out there
man like dude this is 3 500 people bubba
like bring your a game you got 15
minutes he's like i'll figure something
out dude he go we're all watching
backstage and he did it's probably gonna
be on a special and was like the first
kernel of it and just brought the
[ __ ] house down and then gets them
back to the adam was that even [ __ ]
good and we're like what is wrong with
you no i think that's what makes you
destroyed that's what makes a good
comment because the guy's a little
self-conscious of what he's doing uh he
opened for me i write right when i
started to sell tickets i did a show in
san francisco for some [ __ ] comedy
festival that i think comedy central was
putting on and theo
was like there and i needed an opener
and he was headlining his own show but
he's like hey man i'll hop on and do
like 15. i was like cool and i hadn't
seen him perform in a while
and dude i was floored what's up guys uh
i just want to say yeah thanks that i'm
not uh thanks for being here and also
that um yeah i haven't really been in
the studio as much but it's just because
i've been dealing with this netflix
special and uh and
and dylan was just some personal stuff
i've been dealing with so i just want to
let you know i love you and uh
ptl baby praise god you know that and
and um
and i want to thank the uh eric and
stevie uh for holding it down and of
course uh the sting himself uh thank you
guys man i'll see you next week hey guys
what's up uh sorry i can't be there in
studio this week but
um you know what's just as good as
spending some time with with you and me
together
having some liquid iv baby that's right
when you're dehydrated or
if you've had
you know what i'm saying mexican
diarrhea you know or any kind of
diarrhea on any continent
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone and that's
true
go for a run drink some liquid iv man
you feel like a damn ocean maybe you'll
feel like the damn indian ocean i swear
it
first thing in the morning before a
workout after a workout when you feel
run down whenever hydrate treat yourself
contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange as much
potassium as a dang
grab your liquid iv in the bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code k-a-t-s
at
liquidity.com thanks for your support
yo it's everyone's favorite time of year
you know it that's right football's back
some people are vetting on pre-season
football
and i'm one of them that's right
to celebrate draftkings sports book
america's top-rated sports book app is
now putting new players in the center of
the action with 200 in free bets
instantly
if you bet one dollar or more on any
college football game take advantage of
this limited time offer now now if you
have a problem with gambling i i don't
recommend this to you you should call
your sponsor or check with a friend
but otherwise draftkings is giving all
new players 200
in free bets instantly when you place a
bet of one dollar or more
on any collegiate football competition
no matter what head to draftkings
sportsbook app
now now to check out all the great
promotions and daily odds
that's right
it's safe secure and reliable
download the sports book app now and use
promo code k-a-t-t-s
to receive 200
in free bets when you place a one dollar
bet on any college football game that's
the that's the deal
that's promo code kats to get your free
200 in free bets instantly for a limited
time only a draftking sports book must
be 21 or older
new jersey indianapolis or pa indiana
rpa new customers only restrict supply
see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it by the way can someone just
point out that this is how a co a guest
host should talk about the person
they're replacing them not [ __ ] on
me all [ __ ] day on two bears one game
everyone that came on anthony jeselnik's
like that's an interesting choice as a
friend tom why would you ever be
president
[ __ ] ethan klein like bert's movie i
i text tom every time and i was like hey
did they like me like for real and he's
like dude [ __ ] relax they liked you
we're just busting balls i was like well
i'm sitting here in serbia i'm like
[ __ ] broken yeah i'm losing my [ __ ] i
missed podcasting yeah
every day she's getting [ __ ] on it's
like it's i don't know i never get that
oh
i'm saying i never like if if someone
came in here like if you did come in and
just kept chin on theo it'd be a you
know
problem yeah but you know that's your
time i think me and tom's relationship
and i think it's fun and it's funny
because if when you know when it's done
well it's [ __ ] hilarious i mean we do
it with calendar one more time we do
count all the time even still you start
listening to it enough and you're like
you start believing it you're like
when it's like the same [ __ ] over like
all right maybe i do need to work on my
hat they're like yeah finally you get to
talk tom and i was like wait do i have
to over talk over him
wait because he has nothing to say i
mean
i was just trying to make a show yeah i
mean a guy with that many specials you
think he'd talk but oddly enough he just
listens a lot
yeah you you and tom are a great pairing
i [ __ ] love i told tom this and
you're you're in this category you know
i told tom he's he's my north star as
far as like building his network i'm
doing that and just the way he's going
about his career i'm like dude you're my
north star he's my normal it was awkward
like hit them then he's all very cool
you know tommy's like yeah cool see
tom's my north star but the problem with
north stars is they only show up at
night and i sleep the majority of night
true so like i look at the north star
and then i go that's right i got to
focus on my podcast
i just [ __ ] let him run stuff and
then i might only he's good at it my
only thing i focus on the only thing i
focus on really
is stand up stand up and sell tickets
that's the only thing that's always in
my head always in my head about like
we're the best at marketing who tom you
oh no i i think i'm good i i think i'm
definitely better than tom yes i'm way
better than tom i have to tell him how
to market that's usually how it goes
yeah because you usually especially like
it's uh
santino and uh chrissy d and i were
talking about this you look at the best
podcast like pairings
it's you can never it's like having you
know chinese uh fighting fish in a tank
you never want two of them there's
always one guy focus on the business and
then obviously he's good at comedy but
then there's one guy who's kind of the
madman who's loosey goosey yeah you
never want two
like alphas i think that makes up a bit
about it we we saw a couple uh gay
couple one had um khakis on in a white
collar shirt and one had uh jean shorts
cowboy boots and a python oh he's the
he's the powerball he's count he's
khakis on python yeah always always yes
always and he's like i wear pythons like
oh yeah maybe around christina you wear
pythons but around me your khaki's on
python correct and he's like yeah you're
always python i go i'm [ __ ] i'm
perfect example right tom breaks his arm
and breaks his leg
and i just noticed what great marketing
right that's all in the back of my head
what great marketing what an opportunity
we did great numbers with our live
podcast where we showed the video yes
but i feel like he dropped some balls
places and then i blow out my arm and i
go you take your phone into surgery with
you and you do a promo video to promote
your dates
at red rocks september 8th yeah have you
seen my promo video no bring this [ __ ]
up bro
this is how you roll in this is this yes
this is a surgery this is a week ago
this is a week ago wait wait first of
all how do you [ __ ] your arm up i'm not
clear i did uh can we talk about it i
can i was doing a lot of my own acting
and so uh just don't work and [ __ ]
whatever acting and uh and i kind of
[ __ ] my arm up this is the video hey
you gotta hit that you gotta hear audio
and were they cool with it where the who
cares who cares
i told him i said yo i'm rolling in what
i do man i'm rolling into music i want
to be high as [ __ ] and i'm going to
[ __ ] and i told my cardio my
anesthesiologist i'm a kind of [ __ ]
hot promo he goes what what music do you
want i said couldn't get over a rival
and he was like really and i said that's
that's my good luck music is credence
and so he goes okay and he goes and i go
just giving you a heads up jimmy buff is
playing the night before and the night
after me at red rocks i'm forming at red
rocks i'm doing a promo video and i'm
probably going to be high as [ __ ] you
got to remind me to do my promo video
and he was like deal wow
do this anesthesiologist if i get his
name this is the guy you want to put you
under so we go in this is just for the
record before this is this in the valley
is since no this is uh this is uh
curling jobs down in uh down by the
airport okay so i before this i get i'm
nervous i said tom goes tell him to give
you a cocktail and if you don't feel it
tell him to give you a topper and so i
was like okay sweet i say to him hey man
i need my cocktail and he's like you've
already had your cocktail i go i need a
topper and so he goes all right i got
you topper and now this is the point
when the toppers hit and and what is a
topper it's i think it's a cousin to to
xanax it's a fast-acting
xanax so it kicks in daddy in a matter
of seconds and i am the highest i've
ever been in my life and i am on
instagram stories just holding my thumb
down doing minutes and minutes of
stories of me going like fairly
inappropriate i'm not gonna lie to you
like i look at him he's asian i go i
love your accent he's like i don't have
an accent i was like uh whatever you
know the fact that you're asian you're
putting me under here this is you don't
want a white dude putting you under you
want to die his parents held him to a
standard yeah that he had to live up to
that might have been out of his craft
yeah you want an indian guy an eight you
don't want a [ __ ] white dude no you
don't want to like go but hey yin's want
to be put out
no i don't you're from pittsburgh do not
put me out let me see this nick
you are my favorite you are my face of
course i just give you all these drugs
for free you're so high yeah
i'm pretty high i feel like i should
write a poem or something music isn't
that a good buzz yeah you're gonna hear
the credence in the background right
we're walking into the operating room
i'm going into surgery right now
[Music]
but what i want to tell you for real
while i her on this girl
it's red rock september
i will be performing at red rocks
at
burberryburn.com before the night after
i hear waves
[Music]
and so i don't remember filming any of
this right i get in the car i get a call
from tommy because i was really freaked
out about surgery i got a call from
tommy he's like it's not that bad is it
i said no and he goes hey man
you [ __ ] put up a bunch of stories
and i was like what and i had no
recollection of it so i go to my stories
i watch my stories i'm like they're not
too bad they are what they are yeah like
you call me on whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call me on i'm just [ __ ] high
as [ __ ] yeah and and then
and then i and then i go
and then i look at my phone and i go i
shot a [ __ ] promo
and i remember thinking tom really
dropped the ball like he had these great
he put his first
his first surgery video he had a mask on
and they had like a hundred thousand
likes and i went ooh surgery masks do a
lot of numbers huh
good people were like ooh you're about
to die yeah okay oh you might die you
might tune in you might as well like it
might check out let's check out his
website and i thought you're rolling
into surgery you bring a phone in and
you [ __ ] tell everyone and then you
post it and everyone's and you don't
tell him what the surgery is about
by the way these are like marketing
things in my head is do never tell
there's a guy uh there's a guy his
name's young taco right he's part of uh
odd futures he's uh i know this because
he shoot a movie with my buddy uh jimmy
tatro i mean you're a movie star now
yeah i don't know about that you've
changed in january um and so
give me the january yeah give me the
january and so young taco and he's got
some go scroll down scroll down to his
thing right so he's got a few like
operation videos where he's in a he's in
like a medical procedure and all i'm
reading right there and all you read in
the comments is what's going on what are
you in for are you okay
like and so i went okay so don't and he
never tells you why he's in surgery i
think it's cosmetic surgery to be honest
with you i think he's just gonna maybe
have a nose job look look look look read
all the [ __ ] comments are you are you
all right like that's all the things but
he doesn't tell you why he's in there
and i thought okay don't tell them why
you're going in right
don't tell them why you're there let
them wonder let them love you for a
second it's like the time do you
remember the time they thought i had a
heart attack yes
and i told leanne i go do not tell tmz i
did not have a heart attack yeah let me
let everyone think i'm like a simmer let
it simmer and man my phone blew it up
and i'm like oh that's a marketing
opportunity like take what you're seeing
in real life apply it to selling tickets
and we moved like [ __ ] two thousand
tickets in colorado [ __ ]
how many does it hold tenth out they
just had to up the uh
or our capacity was not what it was
going to be and they just upped it all
the way to nike's full capacity you know
who's doing that now is a crowder yeah
he's not a comic but you know he's a
political guy he's like a conservative
or right i don't speak out turn i don't
know what he is but he's a political guy
but he's having like heart surgery what
like yeah his heart like i don't know
he's down like real deal and he i guess
he had surgery and didn't go well so he
has to have it again get those likes
yeah
by the way look at those like last night
for the worst ever actually get so close
that you can physically feel death he's
a dick good news is this fixable things
happen that was july 27th if you go to
his instagram or
he's posting
it didn't go well for him
40 000
[Laughter]
30 40 000 likes now now hang on let's be
real very
on twitter steven crowder is a very
polarizing individual
40 000 likes
40 000 like there are people that hated
them that liked it
you don't want to see anyone die you
don't want to see anyone no like it's
all fun and games so yeah wait how's he
doing what's what i don't i think his
instagram is his last post where he's
like it didn't go well
well either that's and then if he's got
a big uh live show yeah there it is
i don't think does he do live shows i'm
getting heart surgery part two look at
him he's getting heart surgery yeah
we're praying
for a representative yours was so much
more lit yeah you're also more
entertaining by the way nice by the way
hang on pause oh watch live
i wonder how much those live tickets are
go to his [ __ ] website he knows why
he's live by the way steven crowder is a
smart dude he's a very smart kid he's a
he's got he's got i've been here
sorry if you've seen even crowd if
steven crowder is selling tickets to a
live surgery that's [ __ ] game changer
that's a [ __ ] game changer
tired of the left of course you are of
course sign up here stephen crowder man
i've i've heard him on rogan before i've
seen it i've seen him i've only heard
him his co-host his co-host was uh used
to be anthony
comey's co-host oh really oh [ __ ]
hilarious dude those guys get in trouble
all the time and every time i [ __ ] i
can't help but giggle yeah
they don't get in trouble because they
don't i don't think they really care
those guys don't get in trouble i think
he's more on patreon right i think is
that no he's on youtube he's changed my
mind he does all the change my mind
videos and it's it's [ __ ] you know
it's pretty brilliant because you got
stephen crowder's a very intelligent
dude he's a very well researched dude
he's very knowledgeable
about his [ __ ] and he knows your [ __ ]
you don't ever want to get an argument
with anyone that knows your [ __ ] that's
the whole problem with sometimes with uh
with fighting with with uh like like uh
like someone in the audience is they
know everything about you you know
nothing about them yeah we can light
them up with yeah you can line them up
with a few jokes but if someone goes in
real quick and it's like yeah yeah your
younger daughter is dyslexic and you're
like [ __ ] you know more about me
you got kids no all right it's going
nowhere
[Laughter]
wait so is stephen crowder okay
i think yeah i think so i don't know i
said i'm a dm just like hey man we don't
know each other at all
but i think he got mad at me because he
had a guy on and it's a guy that they
don't like and the guy wanted to debate
him and they like caught him
like off guard and he's like i'm not
doing this oh yeah i'm looking at that
h3 yeah yeah he's inclined yeah
so here's the problem
so i don't know any of that world and so
i was like oh but if you're a debater
like why wouldn't crowder just [ __ ]
light that guy up and debate him like
that's what you do best
but i guess they just don't want to give
him a platform so i said that i think it
got to him so he got upset that i was
like dude debate him but i i like
crowder
i said when dan was like dude i hope
your heart surgery went all right by the
way i like crowder i also like ethan and
i also like sam cedar i like all of them
i i don't know any of them that's the
problem is i i actually can like i can
like everyone and that's i'm always that
way this is where you and i are similar
yeah i like everybody i find everybody
everybody [ __ ] entertaining and by
the way and when they don't like me like
oh why not i know you've never been you
ever watched someone and you're like and
you started you like start watching me
like this guy's pretty good this guy's
pretty good or this girl's pretty good
and then a video pop-up of them trashing
you and you're like wow you didn't like
me too oh man yeah i'll dm like hey man
just uh saw your video there seems to be
a
bit of confusion
i shut it down i don't i can't i then
can't watch it i was like oh
should we get in a couple segments yeah
we got some random topics people send in
submission videos talk about whatever
here's one from uh a fella
what up king in the stang
hang it or sting it
county fairs i know up here at the
franklin county fair
all these [ __ ] bums in town here
come out
and uh
get them [ __ ] welfare tickets
[Music]
[Laughter]
i knew that guy was gonna have a beard
there's no way that guy did i did not
think he was gonna look like that i was
thinking of something else it's so funny
i i didn't expect him to be driving a
european car but
because he's on the left wrong side i
guess that's just a video flip he's got
stars and stripes uh seat covers though
so hell just in case you're confused
dude uh i pictured the hat being
backwards i pictured it not being a
fitted cap and i definitely pictured a
beard i expected a woman in there
sipping out of a
mega big gulp a slurpee in the back
maybe a child that had dirt all over his
hands yeah but i didn't you expected
honey boo boo in the back by the way i
can tell you what his car smells like it
smells like a boat yes
that is my wife's family to a [ __ ]
dick no it smells like [ __ ] freedom
you ask me man
so he's asking for about county fairs
yeah here's the thing when you have kids
and you know i have a five-year-old and
a he'll be too soon
when you have kids dude those county
fairs are lit for them it's like
you it's for them it's better than
disneyland no you need a county fair
that serves alcohol yes like if that's
the key and the baby county fairs don't
serve alcohol i've been to the one in
l.a didn't serve alcohol and it was a
[ __ ] exhausting [ __ ] walk yeah so
it basically turns into a walk into a
parking lot of you just going so when do
we get the [ __ ] we get out of here and
then all of a sudden you're like oh [ __ ]
sheep [ __ ] do look like real [ __ ]
they do look like just i swear to god
this well that's why they [ __ ] him and
i didn't know that yeah i didn't know
that because there's nothing but the
sheep they look
i mean if you say have you seen the
sweet game girl she [ __ ] real [ __ ]
where you pull up a sheep [ __ ] or a
real [ __ ] and we gotta guess which one
it is because i'm telling you i could
not really exactly different
i was at a county fair my wife was with
the kids my my my wife's husband's there
and and i'm your wife's husband my
wife's dad
that was a friend
it's a freudian slip and so uh
and we go into the barnyard thing and i
see a sheep from behind and i went holy
[ __ ] and leanne goes stop it i go no it
looks good please stop she's like dear
god she's begging you she's like please
be good she's like i go liam it looks
like you and she's like my dad is right
there
sheep's [ __ ] look
have you seen like the zero dark 30
night vision that the seals use when
they zoom in in the middle east and you
see some dude just [ __ ] a sheep and
they're like all clowning them and
laughing and [ __ ] died [ __ ] a sheep like
here's the thing
if how crazy it would be if they were
like if they were like president bible
was just like hey just so you know
new mass mandate also you can [ __ ] sheep
it's not cheating and it's not
bestiality it's all good it's all good
don't call in sheep sales are through
the [ __ ] roof
no one's eating uh ossobuco at all
nothing i don't even know if that is
that lamb i don't even know [ __ ]
sometimes i say words i don't know what
they mean
but that's my entire career and but i i
would
really
look to it i'm gonna say real [ __ ] i'm
gonna say sheep
real [ __ ] that's a real [ __ ] that's a
real [ __ ] that's a human [ __ ] yes okay
okay by the way they're both real
[ __ ] in my book
okay that's a sheep that's a sheep wait
no that's a wait i see a butthole too
but the butthole's above the [ __ ] yeah
which is flipped around
that's a sheep
that's a woman's foot no i'm just
kidding that's a sheep by the way i
didn't even realize that yeah you're
gonna get butthole above [ __ ] that's a
brand new game that asshole's gonna be
right in your in your in your face
normally [ __ ] are reach in this one
you're like ah right there it's like an
elevator button
that's real [ __ ]
yeah real that's sheep [ __ ]
are there people watching this seeing
this playing along with us it's gonna be
a [ __ ] game show yeah it's gonna be
solid tbs yeah yeah especially in 2021
don't buy this instantly by the way and
the winner has one tooth and his hat
backwards with a beard he goes sheep
[ __ ] real [ __ ] real [ __ ] she's
undefeated undefeated
no one's going to slip me up on this i
bet theo would be great at this game
deal with crush
what else you got nick uh so bird is
ever
kinging oh i'm the hardcore king and
i'll tell you why
the food the food at a county fair
is
is
i mean there's a there's a show called
uh called um my buddy noah capp hosts it
have you ever seen it it's called
carnival eats
was it funnel cakes those dinosaur
turkey legs
oh my deep-fried everything deep-fried
everything deep-fried oreos deep-fried
yeah it's fantastic have you ever seen
carnival eats
everybody's dying if they ate covet
there by the way nobody's in shape at a
county fair no one or disneyland and
part of what i did for travel channel
was i'd go to these [ __ ] county fairs
and ride the rides sometimes top ten i
mean they take food to the next level to
the next [ __ ] level they do things
where you're like the fattest [ __ ] of
all time though deep fried cheesecake
but i love that kind of thinking that
out of the box thinking where you're
like is it out of the box or is it kind
of just fat thinking it's fat thinking
but out of the box fat thinking when
they're like you know
the first person was like just deep fry
a snicker and you're like okay and then
deep fried pizza deep fried everything
then that gets hacky and then you're
like all right what are you gonna do now
and they start doing things where
they're like i i saw them spiral cut a
potato
and then
have that be the outer covering of a hot
dog then deep fry it so that every bite
and then cover it in cheese and chili so
that every bite was was potato
hot dog chili and cheese and it was so
funny look at it look at it
that sounds pretty [ __ ] good
get some fat [ __ ] i love it uh so i'm
gonna king county fairs i was singing
she [ __ ] i got confused on those two by
king sheep
all right you know for 50 years american
home shield has been a company that's
been helping people
that's right
they've protected household budgets from
the unexpected like a dryer that won't
dry
or an ac that's lost its cool you don't
want to not have ac
unless you just don't have it then you
don't even know about it
but
american home shield will cover the cost
to repair or replace parts of over 20
home systems and appliances when they
wear out
no matter how old they are
you don't want to be worrying and
waiting
yup this summer has been going on for a
long time don't let a broken ac fridge
or home repairs get in the way of your
summer fun
i'll tell you this true right when i
moved in on my new house
refrigerator broke
and air conditioner broke
so
it was really i couldn't keep anything
cold i couldn't keep milk cold i
couldn't keep myself cold
if american home shield can't repair the
covered item they'll replace it services
fees limitations and exclusions apply
see plan for details
american home shield members get more
more coverage options fewer exclusions
coverage available no matter how old
your systems or appliances are exclusive
50 offer for listeners of the show
right now to celebrate 50 years of
providing homeowners peace of mind you
can take fifty dollars off their most
comprehensive plans ever
go to ahs.com
kats now to save fifty dollars that's
ahs.com
slash
for fifty dollars off any plan service
fees limitations and exclusions apply so
you plan for details american home
shield be sure with the shield services
fees limitations and exclusions apply
see plan for details
look when you're live streaming you you
got to come up for grub at some point
you ever decided to play one more game
it lasts 40 minutes and next thing you
know you're iron deficient that'll
happen if you're not eating
get something get a pork chop
get something
well grubhub can help they respect
restaurants that's what they do and they
deliver the food exactly the way the
restaurant intended
especially in these tough times you know
we
we need restaurants to stay in business
so we need to them to maintain a level
of expectancy with their dining and
their treats
grubhub does it
yep grubhub is doing a little extra
to serve panera get a free delivery perk
on your first order from panera of 15 or
more that's right grubhub works hard
they want to help the restaurant stay in
business because it helps them stay in
business
order through grubhub app or online
keep your restaurants
whether they're big small whatever type
they are
you want to keep them around so does
grubhub
grubhub
we serve restaurants
racism my name is
i'm from kentucky she is the full metal
one can get her sing it grown men
drinking seltzers the hard ones
specifically black cherry gang gang buzz
buzz buzz buzz pretty young lady
adorable yeah she's super cute
even full of metal mouth no oh by the
way that's i mean but also invisalign no
no design sucks dude is it yeah my wife
got invisalign i go you're getting
plastic surgery at 50 and you're
choosing your teeth yeah like let's
start with your tits yeah
like let's there's a lot we can fix and
you're gonna pick your teeth okay the
last thing i'm [ __ ] looking at is
goddamn teeth i actually like crooked
teeth yeah yeah yeah
what i loved about my wife she got rid
of all of it she had a hole in her face
from a dilated pore i loved it she had a
crooked snaggletooth i loved it i loved
the jewel vibe
i bet she had like randy moss teeth
that's why she had to fix him he's like
that's what you know when you when you
see that
old school braces they're you're like
there's some serious [ __ ] dude it tells
you it's such a commitment adult braces
tell you a lot about a person how so uh
and i i look
it tells you number one their parents
didn't care about their teeth yeah so
their parents didn't care about their
teeth like their parents didn't care
about teeth that's a really important
thing it's like the first line of like
of like of like
middle class is like i'm gonna take care
of my kids yeah anything below that
they're like my wife's family didn't
give a [ __ ] about her teeth did your
wife grow up poor yeah but she's got
like uh like pioneer teeth like you know
like yeah kind of teeth you go [ __ ] it
let's go to a boat ride to america i
don't need a dentist apocalypto tooth
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i have i
have uh i have more settlers teeth yeah
me too yeah
um wait what was her question grown men
[ __ ] selfish oh
i don't [ __ ] with a man like white claw
they always put him in my green room i
don't know why because maybe because i
look like a [ __ ] boy
they'll just have a case of white clown
like who's the i i drink whiskey man
like no you don't oh yeah i'm i'm you
[ __ ] with a white cloth yeah last
night
last night picking up my parents in the
car i got my brace on and leanne goes uh
come on let's go get your parents and i
was like cool i grabbed two bud light
seltzers they have great uh watermelon
flavor and they have the one i really
love is a margarita flavor i killed that
and are they do they sponsor you though
yeah they do yeah
they're amazing they're under 100
they're 100 calories they're refreshing
and if you pick up their summer pack you
go to bud lightdeliveries.com or you can
find it at your local grocer
alcohol we do that read everything have
you done uh coarse pure they're organic
beer it's like nine grams of sugar
no it's like or it might be nine grams
of uh
yeah i think it's nine grams carbs which
makes sense like gram sugar oh dude
it's all organic see like me
i'm not a big bear guy though oh i'm a
big beard i'm straight whistle i'm a big
beer guy i'm a big i'm a big alcohol guy
i'm a big inebriant guy yeah you know
what i just got a sponsor from and it's
more like a
here's the thing it's like we we've been
in podcasting for a long time so we
remember the days when it was
flashlights yes we remember the days
when it was um like when a mattress was
a big get yo
you're not gonna get money but they're
gonna give you a mattress you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah and that was like that was
like that was like uh under the table
money my favorite one is el blento
what's that
can i just give a shout out to the el
blunto guys and see if they can maybe
sponsor you guys maybe theo is not the
best guy for them to sponsor i have a
million shows though el blunto so they
sent me take a look at that the humidor
oh they sent me blunts
in a humidor
and they were like hey man for the
podcast you know and they engraved it
with burt cast on it holy [ __ ] and i
have blunts and so what's really cool
about a blunt is a blunt is like a slow
rolling
weed hit and it's fun man it's like
light a blunt and then just enjoy it and
then let it go out that was snoop taught
me let it go out if you like for me
snoops i'd let him go out he [ __ ]
sucks through them but like smoke it
talk have a good time if it goes out
light it again yeah it's like a
gentleman yeah and and i'm ready for the
like el blunto to get into podcasting i
love that alcohol just got into
podcasting where you get these out like
buffalo trace was the first one
yet correct and i was like and i
remember getting buffalo trays and going
wait this is actually good and like it's
amazing buffalo trace is yeah pioneer i
mean one of the staples old ass bourbon
yeah great and i love that you know uh
there were all the all the the seltzers
the beers i love that where the
sponsorship's going because that's part
of what we all do on a podcast to get
[ __ ] wasted it's it's getting
mainstream for sure oh well i remember
we lost the sponsor
toyota uh got it remember this gin
toyota got in and you know you don't
know the reach to get there and it and i
was like oh toyota's sick big deal but
i'm reena and us pitching their podcast
on toyota cars and i'm when i tell you
we couldn't get through the read me and
brian could not get through the read i
was like if anybody wants to listen to
[ __ ] podcast and we're just roasting the
chat toyota and toys like dude you're
[ __ ] fired man
we can't use this [ __ ] wait bur and i
did a podcast read one time there's like
this is when we were doing podcast reads
in person so i think we only did like
four in person podcast reads so you can
find this read
i think it was about home security
and it was like did you know that 99 of
the people who get broken into get
murdered it was just like
but i forget what the read was but we
were crying laughing and he goes these
numbers are terrifying and we could not
get through the [ __ ] read and then
they were like yeah they've dropped you
guys as a sponsor chin do you have that
totally i'm pulled up right now play
this i'll give it to you i'll give it to
nick dude when i tell you we couldn't we
lost the it was a huge deal we lost the
deal we that's happened before like when
we had uh before with on it we're trying
to find a supplement sponsor we met
we met with the guys we met with the
guys from quest nutrition so me and
brian are there pitching them and
everything's the people that make the
cookies yeah so we were going to sign
this huge
[Music]
huge deal with them so i'll stand around
like you and this we're good to go if
you guys are good we're like yeah it's a
free idea and like we're just waiting
for the president to he should be here
any second and he walks in he has a
toupee on like but like the worst toupee
you've ever seen it was black and shiny
and all i said is i go man i got a set
of hair on you and i can tell the
employers are like
and brian can't stop laughing the guy
sits down and we're laughing so hard
brian has tears in his eyes and the ceo
goes i'm sorry you guys keep laughing am
i missing something and brian goes oh my
god it's brian goes oh he made a stupid
joke it's you we're making fun of the
doll over there and the guy picks up
we're laughing at his hair and the deal
got [ __ ] shot in the hole he's like
you know i think we're gonna go a
different direction and i was like i
don't give a [ __ ]
dude yeah this is the commercial listen
this is trying to get through this read
hey b yeah
you ever just sit around while you're
scrolling through some of your podcasts
and go you know what man
toyota just isn't a car company they're
not i say that all the time i go what
else they are though you know what they
are their new podcast called toyota
untold
what i did is read i did this reasons
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god but i'm like b come on we
gotta get through this i can't
he's like 15 grand dude he's like
pay me
baby okay
tough to get through
let's do this hey who gives a [ __ ] can
we [ __ ] it up you ready you ready
hey b
[Laughter]
ah [ __ ] all right yeah
what's up buddy
damn bro you know what man dude
what's so funny
looks funny bro what
why are you laughing
i can't do
yeah
hey b
you know what one thing i'm noticing a
lot
i can't look at you hold on okay are you
ready you just answered questions yeah
hey b you know what
wait did you put this whole thing in the
podcast
you ever just
sit around
[Laughter]
yeah we lost the dude i remember i
remember the read
you want to hear the story about the guy
that got locked in his car yeah in his
toyota tundra yeah i remember the read
we did i did a bunch of those i it's
funny we sometimes you'll [ __ ] up a
podcast read and we were doing a har
seltzer read i i forget who it was for
and i [ __ ] it up and i said there they
had point zero point zero one percent
alcohol and tom started crying laughing
and i was like what was so funny and he
goes because you know how many you'd
have to drink to get a buzz you'd be
like i cannot have more iced tea in my
[ __ ]
and then i was like but i'm a bad reader
so like yeah i struggle with the reading
you die of over hydration before you got
drunk
yeah who is this guy this guy's uh got a
relationship he's looking for some
relationships david goggins
david goggins it's keegan michael gandhi
he might go you know gandhi used to lay
with women and you lay with young girls
in bed until his dick got so hard it
would bleed i did hear that a couple
years i added the end part but that was
jake started pleasing i don't know it
was blue balls people were trying to
cancel gandhi a couple years ago yeah
people were trying to cancel gandhi and
by the way i think he uh i think he was
like he should have been cancelled like
you know you know hitler's got to be
like i wasn't all that bad
i mean if you [ __ ] gone like hitler's
the king of cancer culture he started it
yeah i read a book about hitler here's
the problem about reading if you're
stupid is you
taking information maybe you shouldn't
have and then all of a sudden any time
anyone brings up any fact i just chime
in like they're like you know we're
starting to lose the population of bees
and i'm like you know hitler's dad was a
beekeeper
it's like okay like you know he had a
dog named blondie and they're like why
are you trying to humanize this guy i
was like
yeah
this guy is looking for some help with
his relationship i just got a little
debate club slash relationship advice
i'm here at the beach right now yep show
your abs having a good time
i was just curious what your thoughts of
um
dumping a girl
from a chick that is not interested in
your hobbies
whether it's
good to give up your hobbies if they're
not into it or not end the relationship
and keep your hobbies going so my hobby
for example is thank you definitely
be in this beach comer
that's a weird hobby tons of shark teeth
out here
uh maryland oh wow he just found it you
know hang on just give me a like he had
that in his pocket or we could see that
he had looks my whole life i've looked
for sharks
my whole [ __ ] life
i grew up in florida and i have stared
at my toes as i walked through the sand
hoping one day i'd find a shark's tooth
you've never found never and i [ __ ]
what
26 years i lived in florida never once
and here telling me he goes and my
obvious oh here's one right here a
[ __ ] tire and it was a black tooth
he's already clean yeah i did this to my
daughters one time i did this to my
daughters i gotta [ __ ] send you this
video i did this to my keep playing the
thing i'm gonna send you this video for
example is
definitely
be in this beachcomber why i think for
him
in order for me to you gotta hear that
you gotta hear the end tons of shark
teeth out here
uh in maryland
and it's just given me a lot of exercise
i can get my good tan going
down over 100 pounds right now
used to be the thick boy what
now i'm kind of getting into that rip
boy no [ __ ] i see you're a [ __ ]
buzz buzz yeah i see the veins it's
crazy bro man he first of all he is down
100 pounds don't lose any more though
dude
i know you're good yeah yeah yeah you're
all set dude mission accomplished look
you can see the v he's got that day yeah
he's the dick roots
is the dick roots dude that is [ __ ]
yeah i think the biggest thing it's like
if it
with the hobby it's like are you combing
the beaches nine to five like is this
all you [ __ ] do
it's kind of like stevie and video games
when he's like yeah man my girl said i
played too much video games like well
that's [ __ ] up and he's like well i do
play 14 hours a day i'm like well that's
a problem yeah it's funny i i don't i
was just talking about this i don't have
any hobbies like i don't have a hobby
like because i when i worked at travel
channel the president lorraine ong sat
me down and was like so what are your
hobbies and i went i write jokes
she was like no that's what you do for a
living and i was like i do videos she
was like that's what you do for a living
i go i write scripts i write books like
i don't like she's like again that's all
work bird yeah and i i don't have a
hobby i've never i don't have hobbies
now oh i i couldn't i can't imagine
having a hobby like your hobby right
it's working out a hobby or is it a
[ __ ]
no no it can't be a hobby it can't be is
that that's not a hobby is it i thought
i thought hobbies like cars you like to
fix up cars i don't touch my [ __ ]
i pay people to do it i don't know how
to work on that [ __ ] machine your
lawn
i mean yeah i mean i'll again i also pay
someone to do that
you want to choose that's a hobby yeah i
guess collecting shoes would be a hobby
right
yeah
i don't know i mean yeah then i i have a
hobby of collecting shirts because i
wear shirts a lot
yeah
yeah i don't have like a hobby like i'm
not making [ __ ] model cars i took up
leathermaking
okay like leather here i'm sending you
this video who do i send it to you
uh on airdrop nick's macbook
get this guy's dick out of my face yeah
wait so wait so like when rogan picks up
hobbies i i'm always suspect of them
because i'm like
like how
like i go how what is going on with your
brain like can you just write jokes all
day like i i i can write jokes all day
and not really do anything else and i
think
i'm always curious why rogan does that
cause i go do you have an addictive
personality though
no
just alcohol
just alcohol though just everything i'm
addicted personality but you're not
addicted to like [ __ ] leather making
or like no but you're not making things
everything turns into everything that
turns into a business yep so i start
making i make a fanny pack and then i go
i bet i can sell these yeah
oh [ __ ] it's gabby reese
she calling right now yeah who's that
are you serious laird hamilton's wife
she's gabby reese hold on one second i'm
doing a podcast right now so you're on
the air what's up
i'm checking on how you're doing oh oh
i'm good okay i'll give you a call when
i get done
all right all right hey you know i'm
performing at florida state i'm forming
at florida state in october
okay oh never mind okay
i mean did you what did you think i was
calling to talk about like um getting
together on a saturday night
i'm like your boring
person
as soon as you said how are you doing i
went of course it's recovery gabby's
going like you need to polar plunge oh
she's a good person oh gabby's a [ __ ]
thanks
oh she cares about your health yeah
she's a good person you need anything
call me and i hope you have a great
podcast all right hey everyone check out
gabby want to promote your podcast real
quick
no goodbye
so it's not all about marketing bert
gabby's [ __ ] amazing she was a
champion volleyball player played
volleyball florida state and while at
florida state signed a huge modeling
deal and was on mtv sports co-host in
mtb sports back in the day um
laird hamilton fell in love they have i
think three beautiful daughters they
live in hawaii half the time hawaii have
two i'm a malibu yeah those kids are
experts you know you know who you know
how you know them is uh every you ever
go to joe's uh podcast and have the
yellow coffee with the turmeric oh yeah
that's them oh yeah their superfoods are
[ __ ] amazing they're like super oh
they're dude they're amazing and by the
way that's a testament to how good of a
person she is is she does not call to
promote does not call to ask to be on a
product just calls you you're like in my
florida state [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] like how's your arm
and you know that she's literally like
hey we're going to be in malibu why
don't you come in rehab with us
because they're all about they do this
uh pool training which i was trying to
get tom to do because it's it was his
arm yeah and so did you did you rogan
says did you [ __ ] up tom's arm when you
put it back in place rogan said i did no
i didn't every doctor says i did the
right thing
every doctor said it was the right thing
to do well dr drew but
he counts yeah he counts uh no he i
didn't i by the way i maybe i did who
[ __ ] knows
but surgery affects it all well they're
gonna at one point they were gonna turn
it back around regardless right i mean
no one was gonna let it live like that
for the rest of his life
and they say that the quicker you turn
an arm injury like that the less nerve
damage you do have and and they said
going in that there were the scented
yeah all right sweet so this is what so
now that we're talking about this this
tiger uh tooth hunter right
and by the way if there is karma i
definitely had the karma by [ __ ] up
my arm and now having to go through
surgery i have so such empathy for
anyone who's gone through any [ __ ]
injury that i go i would have like like
dudes that have been paralyzed that
fight back
i'm like i couldn't do it i put a gun in
my mouth so so that you see that guy in
the in the video collecting tiger's
teeth as a dad you're going to love this
and i wouldn't be shocked to be borrowed
this
so i'll i'll
i'll let you zoom forward i'll tell you
when to start you travel like fossils
right around here right around here so
we're in florida in florida and we're
looking for shells and we can't find any
good shells and my my girls are very
young and i decided to go to the store
and buy some high-end shells and plant
them around the beach for them dad move
super daddy super dab move and watch the
look on my daughter's faces when they
find a shell hit play
you know i found a t-rex tube look at my
daughter right here
ready
i put the shell under my foot i'll hold
your hand and then i'm like i think i
found it
now watch the look on my daughter's
faces when they come up with a shell
here did you get it
oh my goodness look at that
oh my god i feel another one
hold on i want it i want it
it's almost under my foot george george
can you dive down
are you ready i'm not gonna go on this
little girl oh
watch the look at her face
did you get it get it
oh
let me see identical what kind of animal
lives in them
that's dad move ultimate dad move it's
the same exact show
don't you wish you could freeze them at
this age like if my son's one and a half
now he's the cutest [ __ ] thing in the
world oh you're good you're good and so
what did i just want to freeze
well you know what i'm gonna freeze them
you know what uh not a weird way but
like it's
i wish i could i would
it breaks it like i i had i'd had a big
uh award thing in uh hollywood for uh
was that improv yeah i get the email for
it yeah for variety and uh and i i had
my daughters come because i we're doing
a big q a
and uh and i thanked everyone and then i
got to thank my daughters and you just
think of like you know the amount of
time we spend on the road as comics and
it's work and but today is work and and
everything's worked but you you just
struggle to miss some [ __ ] yeah and you
all but you also your work is attached
to your dream like your dream is to is
to is to be able to sell tickets and be
able to do bigger venues and and and and
get a netflix special all the other
things that you're attached their dreams
it's also a job but it's a it's like a
goal
and you and a lot of times your your
family
ultimately i'll ask you sometimes pays
price and they're the ones that pay the
price yeah and so to go back
i go back and i i get very emotional
when i think of like
i should have just canceled the
cincinnati funny bone because and spent
more time with him at the beach yeah
because the way my brain worked and it
was because i was i was broke and i was
panicking and i would go to the beach
we'd go to florida
and i'd say all right uh i can dad can
be there monday
to or tuesday i'll fly on monday tuesday
wednesday i'm leaving thursday to go do
press and i'll be gone for the weekend
and i'll come back and so they spent you
know a week at the beach i only spent
three days with them at the beach so i
think i think that was def partly to
blame for me going they're not finding
any shells [ __ ] it let's make this beat
up yeah you gotta leave on wednesday
let's go to the store buy [ __ ] fifty
dollars worth of shells plant them all
over the beach and then watch them get
shells yep and then one day they're at a
[ __ ] slumber party and their friends
are like hey do you ever see what your
dad did uh
did with that shell thing yeah you're
like huh and yeah your daughter they
play it at a slumber party and your
daughter sees it and then calls you and
you're about to go on stage at the last
paul improv and she goes hey i go what's
up she goes uh i just saw that shell
video and i was like because you posted
when they don't have youtube and you're
like yeah she's like why would you do
that you're like
so you had a great ass time yeah your
dad and she's like it was a lie and
you're like i mean take it easy yeah and
then you go up on stage and light up a
few puerto rican chicks
spend the night in a strip club talking
to strippers going so what did your dad
do wrong
but what i what i've done now i think
the pandemic may realize this like i
used to three four weekends out of the
year for four years straight
and then
you know my first kid i it's not that
you just like if you're gone for four
days when they're like six months old
and you come back they're they've
changed saying different words she's
speaking [ __ ] spanish i'm like what
the [ __ ] i'm gonna play football i'm
like who's the [ __ ] football she's
all dave i'm like who the [ __ ] dave so
the thing is is
now
who the [ __ ] dave but now we'll have
an uncle dave but now uh because the
pandemic me realized that i was at home
like full-time dad non-stop now i only
do two weekends a month like there might
be a a chance i'll do a third in there
if it's like a one night or something
back but as far as full weekends it's
the beginning of the month and the month
and that's the way it's structured now
see so i don't miss too much see you're
very lucky and i think i look at like
you rogan
tom burr all these guys that are very
lucky to have
been establi had a little bit of
established career while they were
having a family and be able to make shot
calls and be like i'm not doing sunday
no i get it i was man when i had kids i
was doing it was 1300 bucks a week at
the improv jesus christ i would get i
get you know 20 offers and that's you
know that was my money for our family i
had to pay for flights hotels
yeah and so
so i didn't like i didn't have an option
i would say i remember going back to the
times when they were babies and they'd
wanted me to read a book and i would
just think i'm [ __ ] you up if i'm
sitting here reading your book i should
be working and trying to make money for
us because i need to make sure we can
pay for christmas i remember being a
broke dad going in for christmas going
to toys r us and seeing other dads
filling their [ __ ] cart and me and my
wife looking at it and my wife's like we
can afford this and i remember if you're
like [ __ ] feeling it was like the lowest
you ever could feel is like you go i
can't even
like my daughters don't know they're not
getting the christmas they should get
and and by the way
they were just they're probably more
happy
then in all honesty i agree then when
you go you're 16 what car do you want
and they just and then they and and then
they're like
i don't i don't need a car and you're
like what the [ __ ] like i finally have
money let me get you the [ __ ] nice
thing i get uber yeah and they're just
like i'm good it's hey it's kevin
jfc
he he uh sent in a topic for us oh i
love kfc is it about talking in his
sleep
yeah that video was creepy we'll watch
that after this um
brendan congrats on thick boy networks
bert congrats on the machine you guys
are both killing it i got one for you
for uh debate club to come straight from
answer the internet would you rather
every time you get in a car
you've got to fight a chicken to the
death
or
once a year you've got to fight a
chimpanzee
but you get a sword oof
oh
but
i don't care if you give me a [ __ ]
gun a chimpanzee's by ripping my face
off every single time correct but
every time you get in the car whether
you're driving whether you're a
passenger whether it's an uber your car
your buddy's car you gotta fight a
chicken drinking death
ripping its head apart breaking its neck
you got feathers everywhere you got a
dead chicken carcass in your car
i'm loading my two kids in the back yeah
and meanwhile it's
a chicken massacre i can have my eyes
and claw on me now
he's never going to kill me i hope a
chicken can't kill me like a chimpanzee
could
but part of me wants to take my chances
train to become like a killer swordsman
and fight this monkey maybe do some
pay-per-view [ __ ] get on showtime with
brendan kfc versus a [ __ ] chimpanzee
with a sword
that would be a hell of a pay-per-view
by the way that would be
chickens man it's just too much of an
inconvenience
i'm going chicken dude before you answer
i'm going chicken because hey i'm gonna
beat the shot thing every time and kill
it and then you have you have chicken
breasts to eat yeah you have [ __ ]
chicken wings every day like think of
all the chicken you'd have oh dude well
first of all you get very comfortable
killing chickens that's my wife like
it's very simple you just grab by the
head like this like shake it there are
people that kill chickens every single
day like to eat there that's a real
thing but it's too mundane i'm not by
the way when he started this i thought
he was gonna say every time you get in a
car you got to blow in a straw to make
sure you're sober enough for it to start
i was like i'll take that
um i'm going chimpanzee sword though no
i'm gonna tell you why love to hear it
first of all pay-per-view number is
gonna be through the [ __ ] roof
marketing but when they see how i kill
the chimpanzee how you can kill that
[ __ ] chimp uh i am gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna it's a slow roll i'm gonna i'm
gonna slow roll this [ __ ] so i'm
gonna start sword by the side he he
won't really understand what the sword
is and i'm gonna just sit there until he
finds his way to me and i'm going to
slowly befriend him you know like you've
seen in the movies yeah they like grab
your nose
and to the point where i put my arm
around him and everyone sees it coming
and i pull the sword up and i just
gently put on his chest and he's like
what's that what's that and i slide it
in
and everyone goes he trusted you he
trusted you and you turned on him and
then i'm gonna [ __ ] pull the sword
out oh dude [ __ ] pretty legit
and you gotta but here's the thing you
gotta
relive that trauma once a year yeah oh i
gotta do it every year every year oh wow
every year every year and like it's
november 21st here goes bert killing a
[ __ ] chimp again hopefully this chimp
realizes he's gonna [ __ ] befriend him
and then stab him in the heart year two
they're gonna be like don't trust him
don't try and the gym is like huh
the trainers will be showing the chimp
the video be like no
dude i had to chimp over on my shoulders
one time um for a tv show and he grabbed
onto my ears and locked in on me and i
remember everyone laughed except for the
trainer who was like whoa whoa whoa whoa
no quick moves no quick moves yeah okay
and i was like what's going on they're
like all right we're all good bye
he literally grabbed onto my ears and i
was like i was like that was scary and
he's like you have no [ __ ] idea
i was like what he goes the first thing
they do is they rip up they bite your
fingers and your genitals yeah and they
just then they go for the face right and
then they go for the face we had a i was
on set with a baboon
and it was it was like a chill baboon
and the trainer was like just don't my
number one advice a don't get too close
you can get a picture yeah don't look at
him in the eyes because then he thinks
you're gonna challenge him he's gonna
rip your [ __ ] face off i'm like okay
cool and then so
everyone's taking pictures of the chimp
and he's got he's put he's cool he's
like putting his arm and then like an
attractive girl comes up and his dick
goes
and dude she got the picture and then
she tried leaving he kept grabbing her
she kept grabbing her just says this
rock hard [ __ ] dick out like god damn
by the way baboon dicks are always out
yeah always out there was a video those
have those big balls there was i was
asleep in a truck in africa one time and
a baboon got in the truck with me and
everyone was laughing hysterically until
it just started to attack me and then uh
and then it broke up really quick but
his dick was out the entire time oh he's
trying to fight yeah i better have it i
better have that video
oh so what's crazy about your iphone is
you can just go to the map
and find all the videos and the places
you've been
like do you ever do that you go to
africa and you're like all right that
was probably tanzania
were you shooting i was in uganda where
were you shooting out there are you
trying to die
no look oh this is definitely it i
guarantee you there's a baboon attacking
me video in here
was it a fight this is the baboon
okay legit baboon yeah that's a baboon
right yeah [ __ ] am i saying it wrong
baboon
i mean you know the video should this
was a [ __ ] this is a fun show trip
flip where you just went around the
world part of your [ __ ] [ __ ] off
and get paid and it was such an
unwatchable show like no one could watch
it make sense
i remember one time we were in a [ __ ]
helicopter in new zealand and we were
flying over this is called glass lake or
something and i said to the guy hey man
i'm afraid of flying is it cool if i
drink and he goes no not at all
i go what he goes i don't want a drunk
person in a bubble with me in air and i
went to point so i grabbed
like a water bottle and filled it up
with whiskey oh yeah and we're flying
over the lake and i'm drinking it
drinking it and he where all those heads
that's on he goes he goes hey man
there's a very close quarters i can
smell your whiskey
sorry and he goes i thought i asked you
not to do that and i was like i didn't
listen yeah i didn't hear you man yeah
did you see they taped that dude to the
[ __ ] seat and spirit airlines they
keep doing it spirit that's what you get
but they keep that there's a very spirit
airlines they should get the duct tape
that's what they keep doing with these
unruly passengers they just [ __ ] i
love it yeah i like it i think they
should start by taping every one of
their seats and you earn the right to
get untaped throughout the floor oh
that'd be cool yeah you're like i like
you in the bathroom they're like hey man
how about you put your shoes back on
you're like oh good call yeah can you
take me now he's like yeah now you get
untaped but uh shout out to kevin clancy
check out his one one minute man and the
kevin clancy show yeah i love that he
does that can i tell you because i i i
never have an opinion on things like i
don't because i i'm i always know what
my first opinion is an ignorant one like
the simone beelace thing
small miles is it biles yeah see i don't
even say her name if you're franchising
i thought it was be late i thought she
was french for some reason oh her name
is simone simone um
i i had a hot take when it first came
out and then you hear all the news and
then your hot take turns and then you
have another hot take and then that
turns again and then another hot take
and then her aunt your aunt died and
then you're like jesus christ man i'm
glad i didn't say a [ __ ] word yeah
because your first initial instinct's
like yo this is what makes champions you
know yeah i double down on that yeah and
then it came out she needed medication
yeah and then you're like well that's
not good but then i was also like it's
kind of a pd thing right okay okay see i
went from you got to be a champion to
like wait what hang on what about andrew
luck what about ricky williams and then
i'm like okay glad i didn't say that
because those because yeah champions
sometimes do get in their [ __ ] heads
and there is thing a thing called the
yips and i had the yeps what the [ __ ] am
i doing so i didn't say it and then they
talked about the adderall and i was like
okay that's a little bit of a p.e.d
and then and then i was like all right
here's my pd and then you're like oh but
yeah actually i need alcohol and drugs
to perform so yeah that makes sense and
then all of a sudden they're like and
her aunt died and you're like okay well
i've been really tough so it's like it's
dicey it's like and i also don't care
enough about gymnastics to really double
down like you're like all right i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah and you go hey man this
is just her life this is also her life
and like [ __ ] it like this yeah but also
get on the beam but i hear you yeah dude
look yeah it's like to have a hot take
and kevin's really good at having hot
takes that are pretty insightful i
always respect people who can like like
rogan's good at that where he's thought
of both sides yeah i'm not that guy i
don't i think of once i think of the
quick funny side yes that's why you and
i get along yeah whatever side has the
most jokes to it i just hammer that
angle and then i'm like oh
[ __ ] i guess meghan markle's not that
bad
uh we've got one more candor stinger
from this guy
coming at you with the king and her
sting it i used to play high school
soccer with this dude and his pre-game
ritual was stroking the old salami
without busting a nut and he swears that
that upped his level of play by like an
unfathomable amount so let me know what
you think about that no not hitter gang
gang blue nuts
thank you ashton kutcher
by the way the guy who looks a lot like
assassin couture a little bit joke's not
funny you got to point it out right yeah
the uh uh
i will say
um
so he's saying jacking off but you don't
nut just to get your testosterone up
yeah just be some to that maybe uh i
just don't want to do it i've had a
couple instances where i got
shut down right at the door right where
i thought we were [ __ ] yeah and it
didn't happen and and then i just was
like
all right and i remember my body
vibrating in both of those instances
like being like
hyper like okay there's something's
going on with me yeah and then you i
one instance i i think i just went and
drank and walked around hollywood at
like four in the morning and then i
think i jerked off in the ocean i was
like i was like i gotta [ __ ] like i
respect you as a human being it's of
your body your choice i'm [ __ ] gonna
go my body my choice into the [ __ ]
gulf of mexico yeah i gotta release the
hounds yeah i i i'm not a guy it's
called uh jim norton does it it's called
um
edging edging not for me i'm not an
edger that sounds like a form of torture
yeah i'm not an editor i'm out no no no
no as a matter of fact i've tried it a
few times and then i just come okay
yeah yeah yeah like i go i go and oh i'm
gonna have that yeah i've never like i'm
not a quitter the only time i've ever
done that is when my blood pressure is
too high and i can't get through it and
you're just like my dick's hard my hands
numb i guess i can't jerk off in brazil
this morning
i've tried that really bad so sting it
it's the hardest hard thing the biggest
thing we've had on here i think
is that it nick that's it
my brother dude thank you for doing this
man yeah i can talk to you all [ __ ]
day dude i could do this all day i love
i i love the podcast and i'm it's an
honor to be a part of it so thank you
yeah you're the best man and uh i mean
you're already selling a gillian tickets
but you're in denver my hometown oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
red rocks september 8th i'm at red rocks
jimmy buffett tonight before night after
and i have acquired mushrooms and i'm
going to be doing mushrooms for the
first time because i the last time i did
mushrooms the girls were babies and i
had a panic attack thinking what if i
break my brain sure
and they need me to survive but george
is going to college next year we've got
that paid for where's she going is
probably i'm trying to get her to go to
boulder see you that's where i went i
want to get her to do a boulder yeah so
so we're doing the show on red rocks and
then and then me and the girls are going
to take a look at boulder colorado state
don't go to fort collins really no place
um boulder and then university of denver
these are my tour dates red rocks uh
vegas on the 25th and then i hit the
road hard october 6th montgomery
augusta i need to move some tickets in
augusta i have a [ __ ] promo video
already planned out for that well i'm
doing that uh i called you because that
bud light uh event center outside of uh
the 18t arena yeah in san francisco
amazing because i was like i was on he
the guy was pitching up to me he's like
bert did it there's a garland called
bird it's funny [ __ ] and i'll tell you
there's one in
i think in fort
collins and there's one in colorado i
did an outdoor amphitheater that they
had set up that was amazing i'm sure
it'll be more looser now but they had it
set up where everyone had their own
little space it was open and it was one
of the best shows i've ever done brian
regan did it the night after me
[ __ ] man i would do amphitheaters in a
heartbeat yeah i'm excited it's
september 24th 25th san antonio yeah in
tallahassee when's my tallahassee date
i'm super excited to go back to
tallahassee i haven't been back to that
college you're all over dude dude i'm
doing a two-week florida run
that is three nights in tampa three
nights in orlando
and then october 24th in tallahassee i'm
coming home the offensive coordinator
just hit me up
he's like yo you want to come to the
game and i was like uh
i was like i have a show in orlando that
night but i'm not i don't give a [ __ ] i
will throw so much money to get me to
tallahassee in the morning party my dick
off i'm gonna have to private it's funny
you're
by the way this is how [ __ ] gangster
i'll take it just to go back to tally
for my first football game i'll fly
everyone private we'll go [ __ ] party
our dicks off and then fly back that
night for the show and then take the
tour bus into tallahassee and i'm
spending three days in tallahassee
[ __ ] hanging out god i'd love to do
that with you can't [ __ ] wait
just out of the show in dc dark
constitutional remember my birthday
birthday show and i'm running the new
york marathon i haven't really announced
that yet oh damn yeah it's my recovery i
i got to set a goal for recovery so i'm
gonna do the new york marathon i just
can't i'm sorry i cancelled the show i'm
in uh
for august i'm in north carolina was
that the 19th and 21st first north
carolina august 19th through the 21st
and then la jolla comedy store end of
the month uh that's a thursday friday
saturday the last month of august i'm at
la jolla comedy store tickets at
thickboy.com or f-a-t-k-z.com
bert i [ __ ] love you dude i love you
too bro thanks for doing this thank you
for having me brennan and theo fighter
and weight i gotta go in and go hard in
the paint i do not think i am in flow
black rifle coffee i'm ready to go i
need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn hungry like i'm fresh off keto
seeing red like andrew santino every
song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you